اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نواصل تغطيتنا الحيه
والمباشره للصراع المسلح في السودان الذي
يعيش حقبه مظلمه ويجعل السودانيين امام
مفترق طرق
[موسيقى]
تنا مستمره لتطورات الاقتتال في السودان
ما زالت دول العالم تسابق الزمن لاجلاء
رعاياها وهدوء حذر يسود العاصمه الخرطوم
يتخلله اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع داخل العاصمه وخارجها اعداد
الضحايا من المدنيين تقترب من 300 قتيل
وكارثه صحيه تضرب البلاد حيث خرجت نحو 70%
من المستشفيات عن الخدمه جراء القصف
واشتباكات متقطعه بين الجنرلين البرهان
وحميتي بينما تبادل الاتهامات او تبادل
الاتهامات لم ينقطع وذلك مع استمرار
انقطاع خدمات الاتصالات والانترنت في
السودان وبشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
افاد موقع رسب للانترنت استمرارا قطاع
خدمه الانترنت في السودان بشكل شبهي كامل
وذلك مع استمرار الاشتباكات بين قوات
الدعم وقوات الدعم السريع والجيش لليوم
العاشر على التوالي حيث اظهرت بيانات
الشبكه انهيارا شبهي كامل للاتصال
بالانترنت لتصل نسبه الاتصال الى 2%
مقارنه بالمستوى الطبيعي لشبكه الانترنت
بحسب منظمه
لرصد الوصول الى شبكه الانترنت في العالم
مع استمرار المواجهات بين المكونين
العسكريين في السودان يدفع المدنيون الثمن
كعاده اي صراع خاصه وان كان مسلحا حيث
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع عدد
الوفيات منذ بدايه الاشتباكات الى اكثر من
270 من المدنيين النقابه سجلت نحو 1580
حاله اصابه منذ بدايه الاشتباكات مؤكده ان
العدد مرشح للزياده مع صعوبه في الحصر
الدقيق بسبب صعوبه التنقل بين المستشفيات
النقابه اشارت الى ان 69% من المستشفيات
متوقفه عن الخدمه مضيفه ان 13 مستشفى
قالها القصف و9 عشره مستشفى اخر تعرضت
للاخلاء القصري وذلك جراء الوضع الامني
الراهن
وفيما وافقت الصور تصاعد اعمده دخان في
محيط السفاره الكويتيه في الخرطوم اثرى
الاشتباكات الدائره
نشير الى هذا العاجل امامكم على الشاشه
مشاهدينا حيث يقول الجيش السوداني ان
الموقف العملياتي مستقر بشكل ملحوظ اذا
الجيش السوداني يقول بما يخص الاشتباكات
في السودان بان الموقف العمليات مستقر
بشكل ملحوظ وان قواتهم مستمره في توسيع
نطاق وتامين الخرطوم واما قوات الدعم
السريع فقد اتهمت من اسمتهم عناصر النظام
السابق بتنفيذ عمليه تخريب واسعه من بينها
نهب منازل المواطنين ومقر الشركات
والمصانع واعتبرت قوات الدعم السريع ان
هناك خطه مشبوهه بتنفيذ عمليات سلب ونهب
والصاق التهمه بعناصرها مشيره الى انها
تعمل على تامين مصادر الخدمات الضروريه
مؤكده انها ليست مسؤوله عن انقطاعها وقالت
قوات الدعم السريع انها تعمل على توفير
الخدمات الضروريه للمواطنين وتامين مصادر
هذه الخدمات
الجانبي تامين عمليات اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعايا الدول الاجنبيه وتامين
الطرق وتسهيل عبور المواطنين الى المناطق
الامنه
هذا ونشر للجيش مقطعا مصورا لانضمام احد
ضباط الدعم السريع وذلك استجابه لدعوات
سابقه طلبت عناصر الدعم السريع بالاستسلام
انا الرايت حسين هدايا عمر
قوات الدعم السريع والان انضميت
الان انضميت للقوات المسلحه
وباغرار
الاغرار القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ومهاي 125 فرد وخمسه وعشرين عربيه
وبناشد اخواني في الدعم في الدعم السريع
لسه ينضموا للقوات المسلحه لحقن للدماء
ولحقنا للدماء وانا بناشد اخواني كلهم في
الدعم السريع والجيش انضم وكل من انضمه في
اقرب القوات المسلحه ونحن متكيفين ذات
القرار السيد الغايب
لارجاع قوات القوات الحرس الحدود للقوات
المسلحه
[موسيقى]
اصبحت مدينه الابيض الان امنه سالمه هانئه
مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح الاسواق
ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
[تصفيق]
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
نشير الى هذا العاجل امامكم على الشاشه
مشاهدينا حيث تقول الحكومه الفرنسيه بانها
اغلقت سفارتها في السودان حتى اشعار اخر
اذا فرنسا تغلق سفرتها في السودان حتى
اشعار اخر وفي هذه الاثناء قال مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل بان الكتله الاوروبيه لن تسمح
بانفجار الوضع في السودان واضاف على هامش
اجتماع لوزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
عمليه اجلاء موظفي الاتحاد قد نجحت
لقد كانت عمليه معقده لكنها ناجحه موظف
الاتحاد الاوروبي 21 شخصا موجودون بالفعل
في اوروبا والعديد من مواطني الاتحاد
الاوروبي خارج السودان بالفعل لا استطيع
ان اعطيك الرقم الملموسه لكن تقريبا اكثر
من الف شخص اود ان اشكر فرنسا على
مساهمتها علينا ان نواصل الضغط من اجل
تسويه سياسيه لا يمكننا ان نتحمل ان ينهار
السودان لانه سيرسل موجات صدمه في جميع
انحاء افريقيا
بوريل قال ردا على سؤال للعربيه ان
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على المكونين
العسكريين في السودان ويقوم ببذل جهود
مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب للوصول الى تسويه
سياسيه
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على الطرفين ويقوم
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه لقد كنت اتحدث مع جميع
الجيران وجميع الاصدقاء حتى مع وجود
الجنرلين الذين يقودان القوات رساله
المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب واسكات
المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث عن الحل
السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذه الحرب
وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج مواطنينا
لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك تراه انت
تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج مواطنونا
ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
معنى من مدينه نيوهيفن الامريكيه الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني فايز الشيخ
السليك اهلا بك سيد فايز معنا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره لاحداث السودان اذا
بدايه وبما انك في الولايات المتحده ومع
اجلاء المواطنين الاجانب الامريكان من
السودان برايك هل من دور فاعل يمكن ان
تلعبه الولايات المتحده في حلحله هذه
الازمه
تحيه لك ولكل مشاهدي قناه العربيه والتحيه
ايضا لشعبنا في السودان ونتمنى ان نعبر
هذه المحنه واكثر قوه واكثر تماسكا فيما
يتعلق بمساله
المجتمع الدولي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على وجه التحديد الولايات
المتحده بدات مجهودات
لدعم الفتره الانتقاليه واصدرت قانون لدعم
الانتقال
والتحول الديمقراطي لكن عمليا منذ ان وقع
انقلاب البرهان ياتيكي اكتوبر عام 2021
وحتى اليوم لم يكن هنالك تفعيلا مباشرا
لهذه القانون هذا القانون
يحمي عقوبات مباشره على الافراد مثلا في
مثل هذه الاحداث او الذين يعطرون
الانتقال ويرفضونه تكوين حكومه
هكذا تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في الرباعيه بعد الانقلاب ومعروف الرباعيه
الى جانب واشنطن تضم ابوظبي والرياض ولندن
هذه العاصمه الاربعه كانت هذه اتفقت على
ضروره استرداد الانتقال الديمقراطي بعد
احداث او بعض انقلاب 25 اكتوبر عام 2021
وبدات هذه الرباعيه في تقديم الدعم لقوى
الحريه والتغيير والمكونه العسكري من خلال
التسهيل المفاوضات حول اتفاق اطاري
لعمليه سياسيه كامله لكن هذه العمليه وصلت
الى طريق مسدود وكان التحرك العسكري
الاخير او الانقلاب هو واحد من
المسببات التي اوقفت العمليه التنميه وفي
ذات الوقت كانت العمليه السلميه واحده من
الاسباب التي عجلت بهذا التحرك العسكري
لكن بعد ذلك لم نلمس اي تحرك سوى النداءات
ومبادرات معلقه في الهواء لابد من يجوز
خطط واضحه لابد من وجود رؤيه بملام الطريق
مثلا عقوبات او او حوافز للاطفال متصارعه
لكن غير ذلك تكون مساله وحسن نوايا وحسن
نوايا لا يمكن ان تقدم شيء
يعني قال في سياق حديثه وكلامه انهم
يفسحون المجال للاتحاد الافريقي ليتخذ
اجراءات معينه ولازمه وخطوات لحلحله هذه
الازمه وربما الوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
برايك هل يمكن لي الاتحاد الافريقي ان
يلعب دورا فاعلا هنا
صبغه للاتحاد الافريقي لعب دورا كبيرا في
مساله اتفاق
الحريه والتغيير مع المكونه العسكري في
عام 2019
وكان ذلك جزء من المجهودات المدعومه في
المجتمع الدولي بدون شك لكن كما قلت بدون
خارطه بدون ملامح بدون فعل وهذه الخارطه
او الرؤيه التي ذكرتها سيد فايز هل يمكن
للاتحاد الافريقي ان يقدمها هل يمكن ان
يقدم رؤيا او خطه
تساهم في ان يتفق الطرفان عليها
اولا عم يطرح هذه الرؤيه اين هي الرؤيه او
حتى لو طرحها للاطراف سرا مثلا احيانا
تقتضي بعض الظروف بعض بعض السياقات ان ان
تقدم المبادره او
الى المبادره للاطراف المعنيه بها مباشره
لكن لم نسمع عن اي اتصال مباشر
لتقديم اي مبادره مباشره لذلك تقول بان
ليس هنالك حتى الان مبادره وكل ما كل ما
نسمعه هو
نوايا ونداءات
مثلا
المتحدث الفرنسيه او الاوروبي تحدث عن
انهم سيغطون على الحكومه السودانيه في ذات
الوقت هم سحبوا قنوات البخت قنوات
الاتصال
الدبل
وماسيه من اهم وسائل التواصل مع الحكومات
الولايات المتحده اغلقت سفارتها مثلا
فرنسا اغلقت تفاردها
يبقى التواصل الا من على البعد هذا يثير
على ماده
[موسيقى]
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه نيوهيفن
الامريكيه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني فايز الشيخ سليك
مشاهدينا نذكر بهذه العواجل التي اتتنا
تباعا اثناء حديثه مع ضيفي الجيش السوداني
يقول ان قواته مستمره في توزيع نطاق تامين
الخرطوم وان الموقف العملياتي مستقر بشكل
ملحوظ وايضا جدد الجيش السوداني الدعوه
لعناصر الدعم السريع بالخروجي عن دائره
التمرد وكان هناك فيديو يوثق ذلك واكد ان
مجموعات الدعم السريع تبعثرت على نطاق
واسع في الخرطوم وتحتمي في الاحياء
المدنيه الجيش السوداني قال ايضا ان هناك
اتصالات مستمره مع دول مختلفه لتامين
اجلاء بعثاتها ورعاياها وايضا قال بان
هناك لا صحه لسيطره الدعم السريع على اي
مواقع بالقياده والقصر الجمهوري وبان
مجموعات الدعم السريع تتخذ المدنيين دروعا
بشريه
من الرباط ينضم الينا رئيس مركز شمال
افريقيا للدراسات والابحاث وتقييم
السياسات العموميه الدكتور رشيد لرز
الازرق اهلين مع اهلا دكتور رشيد اهلا بك
معنا في هذه التغطيه المستمره لاحداث
السودان لنبدا حيث انتهت العواجل يعني
الجيش يقول بان الدعم السريع يحتمون في
الاحياء ويستخدمون المدنيين كدروع بشريه
في هذه الحاله كيف يمكن التعامل مع الحرب
التي يعني يحتاجون حسمها يعني هل يمكن حسم
هذه الحرب اثناء استخدام البشر كدروع
بشريه استخدام الاحياء كمخابئ
هي بدايه دخول في حرب شوارع
بخسائر ماديه خسائر بشريه كبرى وبالتالي
فان هناك في تل غياب الرؤيه وفي ظل عدم
اتضاح موازي القوى داخل بين الطرفين
المتسارعين فان نلمس بان غياب اراده دوليه
جاده في انهاء هذا هذه الحرب حتى تتضح
معالم الاعتبار ان هناك اضرار هناك اطراف
اقليميه ودوليه
تعتبر السودان منطقه جيوش استراتيجيه نحو
افريقيا وستكون لها تداعيات على شمال
افريقيا ومن ثم فان وزنها في السودان
سيحددها في الاستراتيجي وعليه فهذا هو
وهذا وما يؤكد تردد تردد القوى الاقليميه
والقوى الدوليه في تدخل حاسم لوقف هذه
الحرب في السودان اذا تدخل الحاسم لمعركه
لابد ان تحسم دكتور ولكن يعني ذكرت رؤيه
لابد ان تطرح برايك ما هي الرؤيه التي
يمكن ان ترضي الطرفان
الرؤيه التي هي نتيجه لباس يقع في الساحه
وبالتالي فان كل طرف يحاول ان يقوي موقعه
والتفاوضي من خلال مكاسب الساحه السودانيه
لانها هذه المكاسب هي التي ستكون اهليته
للتفاوض مع الطرف الاخر لان في الاخر فان
معركه غير وجوديه بين الطرفين لان معرفه
تحسين موقف التفاوري اكثر ما هي معركه
الغاء كل طرف الطرف الاخر طيب ابقى معي
دكتور لنعود اليك تباعا وللحديث بقيه
وعلى الحدود بين مصر والسودان دعونا نشاهد
هذه الصور لعبور عدد من شاحنات الاجلاء
الى الاراضي المصريه وتشهد الحدود المصريه
السودانيه استنفارا امنيا وفقا لمراسل
العربيه حيث وصلت دفع جديده من الحافلات
لانهاء الاجراءات لدخول الاراضي المصريه
وافاد ايضا مراسل العربيه بانه من المنتظر
وصول عدد من حافلات الاجلاء خلال الساعات
القادمه
من القاهره تنضم الينا الدكتوره اماني
الطويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات اهلا بك معنا دكتوره
بدايه لنبدا بتقييمك للوضع على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه كيف تجري الامور برايك
اهلا بك وبالمشاهدين الحقيقه يعني تجري
الامور بشكل جيد لان مصر قد دعمت قدرتها
القنصليه في وادي حلفا وهي تعطي تاشيرات
دخول كل منهم تحت 45 سنه من الرجال بينما
دخول النساء
والاطفال في اي سن متاح وبالتالي هناك
تسهيلات مصريه كبيره لاستقبال السودانيين
الاشقاء في مصر ايضا يعرض المصريون
والسودانيون الذين يملكون شققا في مدينه
اسوان باستقبال هؤلاء القادمين من مناطق
الهلع والرعب حتى يستريحوا كي يجدوا
قطارات للقاهره بعض الاسر المتيسره من
السودانيين تغادر من اسوان الى القاهره
بالطائرات
الحقيقه مصر بتحشد جهودها من اجل استقبال
المصريين والعالقين في السودان
والاشقاء من السودان وبتبذل مجهودات جباره
في هذا السياق بالاضافه ان يعني
بيتم استقبال السودانيين في القاهره ليس
في معسكرات ايواء ولكن هم جزء من التكوين
الاجتماعي المصري 20 كالمصريين في شقق
واحيانا يمارسون اعمالا وما الى ذلك فهم
يعيشون في القاهره حياه طبيعيه
وتضاف في هذه الحاله هذا الملوح السوداني
الجديد يضاف الى النزوح الموجود في
السودان بالفعل وهو يعني تختلف التقديرات
بشان حجمه ولكن هو يعني رقم يتراوح ما بين
خمس ملايين سوداني الى سبع ملايين سوداني
طيب دكتوره هل هناك مخاوف من ان تمتد
الازمه من السودان الى مصر
يعني باي معنى انا اشك معنى ان العدد
النازحين يزيد الى الداخل المصري يبدا
يكون هناك ربما مشكله في اعداد النازحين
والداخلين الى الاراضي المصريه
شوفي هو في في حقيقتين من الحقيقه الاولى
لحصتها من خلال السنه الاخيره انه معظم
الفئات الوسطى في الطبقه الوسطى السودانيه
الصحرا يتملكون شقا بالقاهره
والاسعار في القاهره في العقارات اقل
بكثير
من الرموز السياسيه السودانيه قد امتلكت
خلال العام الماضي سقفا بالقاهره
بتبقى المشكله اساسا في القادمين
بملاءات ماليه محدوده
هؤلاء احيانا يمارسوا انشطه غير مشروعه
واحيانا يشكلوا مشاكل تجاره في العمله
انواع من الاعمال الغير مقبوله قانونين
وغير ذلك لكن على اي حال هناك نوع من
انواع الحساسيه المصريه الشديده في
التعامل مع هذه
الحالات
التعامل بمنهج احتوائي بشكل او باخر حتى
لا تتفجر مشاكل لها طابع اجتماعي في مصر
يعني انا رايي ان السلطات بتحاول قدر
الامكان ان تحتوي الاوضاع
والناس العاديه بيستقبلوا السودان اولا
بيستقبلوهم يعني وخصوصا نازحين الجدد
باعتبارهم قادمين من مناطق حربائهم
واكرامهم هذا واجب على المصريين ثانيا
احنا الحقيقه على المستوى الوجداني
والشخصي مفيش فروق بيننا وبين السودانيين
يعني واضح ودين معانا وما فيش مشكله يعني
بنتعامل مع بعضنا البعض باريحيه شديده
وهم مواطنين يعني
ويستخدمون خدمات الصحيه والثقافيه تقريبا
زي باسعار المواطن تعليمات طيب ما توقعاتك
دكتوره للحرب والاشتباكات في الداخل
السوداني يعني هل ترون بانها قد تمتد
وتطول امدها
يعني حتى الان انا ما اراه على الارض هو
توازن الضعف والمعلومات التي تصلني من
الخرطوم عبر اصدقائه هو انه في تداخل كمان
في بين نقاط لارتكاز لكل من القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع وربما البرهان
في حديثه بالامس الى العربيه قد اشر الى
ذلك في منطقه الخرطوم مثلا في منطقه مطار
الخرطوم هناك جهه من المطار يسيطر عليها
الجيش وهناك الجهه الاخرى وهي الجهه التي
اعلم انها تابعه يعني ابنيه المخابرات
السودانيه بيسيطر عليها الدعم السريع ايضا
في الاحياء وخصوصا في بحري في تداخل في
نقاط الارتكاز بين الاطراف وبالتالي ده
اولا يرشح الموقف لتصاعد على حساب
المدنيين يعني تصاعد العنف على حساب
المدنيه
اتنين في تقديري اذا
قوات الدعم السريع حصل لها خلخله كبيره
وانا شايفه في مؤشرات للخلخله سواء
بانسحاب قوات زي ما الفيديو اللي برضو
حضرتك العربيه بسته من قائد عنده 25 سياره
دفع رباعي انضمام القوات المسلحه بيان
القبائل العربيه للصدا القبل ثلاثه ايام
بدعوه ابنائها من ابناء تشاد للانسلاخ عن
قوات الدعم السريع كل ده الحقيقه بيفتت
قدرات الدعم السريعه متى يمكن ان تكون
يكون الدعم السريع رقما وازنا على الصعيد
الميداني حينما تلقى دعما عسكريا من احد
الاطراف الاقليميه
يبدو بان هناك مروحيتين طابعتين للجيش
في صور متداوله تقصيفان مواقع للدعم
السريع اثناء حديثنا دكتوره في منطقه
فتيحه بشمال اوم اقتحاب في شمال ام درمان
اذا صور متداوله لمروحيتين تقصفان مواقع
للدعم السريع في منطقه الفتيحاب شمال ام
درمان نتابع هذه الصور التي وردتنا
مشاهدينا لهذا القصف
[موسيقى]
اذن دكتوره اماني ساعود اليك بقي معني معي
رجاء نواف السياق مشاهدينا اعلنت سويسرا
اغلاق سفارتها في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم واجلاء موظفيها وعائلاتهم من بسبب
الوضع الامني جراءه المواجهات المستمره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع واضافت الوزاره
انها تمكنت من ذلك بفضل التعاون مع
شركائها وخاصه فرنسا من دون ذكر عدد
الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم
من جانبها وفيما تتسارع عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان اعلنت الخارجيه الصينيه انها
ارسلت قوات مهمات للسودان واجلت مجموعه من
الموظفين والمواطنين في امان الى احدى دول
الجوار وذكرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه
تتابع التطورات في السودان عن كثب وتؤيد
جهود التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار
اما فرنسا فاعلنت انها تواصل عمليه اجلاء
رعاياها ودبلوماسيين من السودان باريس
كررت دعوتها لوضع حد للقتال والعوده الى
المحادثات السياسيه
لا تزال على اتصال وثيق بشركائها حول
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار المواجهات الازمه اخرى تلوح
في الافق ازمه صحيه وفي سبيل ذلك طالبت
منظمه الصحه العالميه بعدم استهداف
المرافق الصحيه والعاملين والمرضى بعدما
وثقت عده هجمات مميته استهدفت المؤسسات
الصحيه
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السودان اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
المتقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتلى ب122 ثلاث
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور ب 61 قتيلا في عدد
المرشح للزياده المعوقات اللي نحن بنواجهك
هلال السوداني واجهها كل المنظمات
الانسانيه العامله في السودان اللي هي
ابرزه عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه من جانبها اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء ان 72% من المستشفيات القريبه من
مناطق الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل 79
مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه والولايات من
المجموعه الكلي للمستشفيات بقي اثنتان
وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او جزئي
لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر فيها
الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الوصول
اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان اربعه
مستشفيات في مدينه الابيض تعرضت للقصف ما
يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات التي قصفت
الى 13 مستشفى مستشفى يضاف اليها تسعه عشر
مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء القصري كما تعرضت ست
مركبات اسعاف للاعتداء من قبل قوات عسكريه
بينما لم يتم السماح لعدد من سيارات
الاسعاف بالمرور لنقل المرضى وايصال
المعونات حسب ما قالت نقابه اطباء السودان
من جانبه طالب الهلال الاحمر بتحييد
المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات القتاليه
لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع الصحي في
السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
ازمه اخرى تزيد من معاناه السودانيين ازمه
مياه اوجدتها الاشتباكات الدائره بين طرفي
الصراع
الناس
شبه كل سوق من المشكله بتاعه المويه
يعني لا توجد اننا ماء تماما ولا يوجد
عندنا كهرباء فكنا
في
نشير مشاهدينا الى هذه الصور امامكم على
الشاشه حيث ترون على الجهه اليمنى اعمده
دخان تتصاعد في العاصمه الخرطوم والجهه
اليسرى ايضا للعاصمه الخرطوم ولكن من
زاويه اخرى اذا ننقل لكم صور مباشره
للعاصمه الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات الصوره
امامكم في الجهه اليمنى تظهر اعمده دخان
تتصاعد في العاصمه الخرطوم اثر الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع المستمره واثناء
الهدنه التي توشك على الانتهاء كذلك
نعود الى الرباط وضيفي من هناك رئيس مركز
شمال افريقيا للدراسات والابحاث الدكتور
رشيد الازرق دكتور رشيد اعود اليك يعني
هناك اتهامات للدعم السريع بتجنيد مقاتلين
من دول مجاوره من اسلحه من مال وما الى
ذلك سؤالي من اين لهم القدره على تجنيد
جنود من خارج السودان
بدايه بان الدعم الشعبي يمتلك قوه عاليه
من الذهب على اعتبار الاحتياطي الذهب الذي
يملكه وكذلك هناك علاقات بينه وبين اطراف
الجوار وكذلك الخبره التي اخذها في معاركه
في ليبيا وبالتالي فان هذا الدعم الماليا
والعلاقات
الاجتماعيات تؤهله لاستقطاب من الدول
المجاوره وكذلك من المرتزقه
طيب دكتور يعني الاشتباكات المستمره بين
الدعم السريع والجيش رغم الهدنه ولكن هناك
تهدئه يقال بانها تهدئه لاجلاء الاجانب من
السودان بعد هذه التهدئه برايك هل يعيدون
او هناك اعاده لترتيب صفوفهم ام انهم
بالفعل يعني يودون التهدئه ويودون
الاستمرار في هذه الهدنه
بين قوسين او بين ظفرين
اهم العامل الاول هو اخلاء الرعايه
الاجانب خاصه الكبرى من ميناء السودان هو
العامل الثاني هو اعاده تمركز هذه القوات
واستراحاتها واعاده توقعها داخل السودان
في استراتيجيه بداء المرحله لان ليس هناك
مؤشرات لانتهاء المعركه او لان المعركه
ستقوم ستقف عند حد المهبل كل طلب في
الساحه السودانيه يريد الانتصار ليكون
ليحمل هذا الانكسار او ورقه في اطار
التفاوض بين الطرف الاخر للحصول على
المكتسبات وما يقوي هذا هو ان الاطراف
المجاوره والاطراف الاقليميه بدورها تنتظر
تداعيات المعركه في الساحه السودانيه لكي
تتدخل ولا زال كل طرف يراقب
الطرف لان في داخل السودان هناك مصالح
قطرات الدول المجاوره بدون شك وهناك مصالح
الدول الدول الكبرى وبالتالي هذا ماشي
يوصل الاجماع السودانيه
مصالح دول اخرى ستسير الازمه في الداخل
السوداني طب سؤالي هو دكتور المجتمع
الدولي يعني طرح بان هناك او قيل بان هناك
ربما عقوبات ستفرض على الطرفين ماء ااا
يعني لجاوا الى وقف اطلاق النار ولجاوا
الى تسويه سياسيه وتهدئه الاوضاع في
السودان بسؤال هو ما هي العقوبات التي
يمكن ان تفرض عليهم وعلى اي الجانبان ام
اثناهما
العقوبه ستفرق على اي مستوى هل ستفرض على
مجلس الامن مجلس الامن لازال معطل وزال
داخل الاطراف التي تملك حق الفيتو لا زالت
متضاربه
العقوبات التي يمكن ان هي حرماله من
السلاح والحاله ان كل طرف كل طرف اقليمي
يجود الطرف
الاخرى لاستضافه المعركه بمده اطول اطول
مده والتي ستخلف خسائر كبرى لان نيجي الى
حدود الان ليس هناك اراده دوليه حقيقيه
لوقف هذا الصراع على المدى القريب
طيب دكتور يعني سالت ان هذا السؤال لضيفه
دكتوره اماني من القاهره عن امد الحرب
برايك وفي ظل المجريات والمعطيات على ارض
المعركه هل ستطول امد الحرب ام ستحسم
قريبا
انه
هو
له اتباع اقليميه ودوليه وبالتالي فان هذا
الحرف ستوقفها ليس بيدي الاطراف المتصارعه
بل بيدي دول الجوار وبيدي الدول الاقليميه
وبيدي
الاراده الضوئيه والحال ان الوضع الدولي
والوضع الاقليمي والوضع دول الجوار ووضع
متسارع مما يزيد قوه بان هذه الساحه
السودانيه بان وقف هذا الصراع الى غايه
غايه ان تظهر معالمه معالم الصرع والحال
ان لا زالت لم تظهر معالم الصراع الاقوى
في الساحه السودانيه شكرا لك من الرباط
رئيس مركز شمال افريقيا للدراسات والابحاث
وتقييم السياسات العموميه دكتور رشيد
الازرق وشكر ممتد لضيفتي من القاهره
دكتوره اماني الطويل مديره البرنامج
الافريقي في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
كشف وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكار ان
اجتماعا رباعيا يضم تركيا سوريا روسيا
وايران سيعقد غدا في العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو يذكر ان عمليه تطبيع العلاقات بين
انقره ودمشق كانت قد انطلقت في نهايه
ديسمبر العام الماضي في موسكو عندما جرت
مشاورات بين وزراء دفاع روسيا وسوريا
وتركيا وتم خلال الاجتماع على الاتفاق على
تشكيل لجنه ثلاثيه مشتركه
كما تعلمون عقد اجتماع في موسكو في 28 من
ديسمبر الماضي حضره وزراء الدفاع ورؤساء
المخابرات من تركيا وروسيا وسوريا
وتبادلنا وجهات النظر واتفقنا على حل بعض
المشاكل واستئناف هذه اللقاءات في
المستقبل كما ناقشنا مشاركه ايران في هذه
الاجتماعات وتم الاتفاق على ذلك لاحقا
واستمرارا لذلك نستعد الاجتماع سيعقد في
موسكو في 25 من ابريل بحضور وزراء دفاع
ورؤساء مخابرات الدول الاربع
كشفت مراجعه عسكريه ان الحكومه الاستراليه
تحتاج لانفاق المزيد من الاموال على
الدفاع في الوقت الذي يشكل الوجود العسكري
الصيني تحديا للامن الاقليمي المراجعه
اوسط ايضا بزياده الانفاق على تصنيع
الذخائر وتطوير قدره قوات الدفاع
الاستراليه على ضرب اهداف بعيده المدى
اعلن حاكم مدينه سيافو ستوبول في شبه
جزيره القرم ان قوات اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي دمرت مسيره مائيه واحده في محيط
مدينه يافاست بول وانفجرت اخرى من تلقاء
نفسها مشيرا الى عدم وقوع ايه اضرار تجدر
او تجدر الاشاره الى ان سيفاستوفول هي
القاعده الرئيسيه لاسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي وهي الاشهر الاخيره او في الاشهر
الاخيره جرت عده محاولات لمهاجمتها في
مسيرات جويه ومائيه
يتوجه رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه الى واشنطن في
زياره تستغرق سته ايام حيث يعزز الحلفاء
التعاون العسكري بشان برنامج الاسلحه
النوويه الموسع لكوريا الشماليه كما سيبحث
الطرفان سهوله تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين
وايضا مناقشه التطورات الحاصله بخصوص
كوريا الشماليه والحرب على اوكرانيا
كشفت دراسه قام بها باحثون في مجال الامن
بمعهد ستوكهولمان معدل الانفاق العسكري في
اوروبا ارتفع بوتيره سريعه وغير مسبوقه
واشارت الدراسه الى ان اوروبا عززت
انفاقها على جيوشها عام 2022 بنسبه 13%
مقارنه بالاشهور السابقه وتحديدا بعد
الحرب على اوكرانيا حيث تم تسجيل رقم
قياسي للمره الثامنه على التوالي بمعدل
2.24 تريليون تريليون دولار وهو مستوى لم
تشهده القاره منذ الحرب البارده وفق ما
افادت به الدراسه
يعقد مجلس الامن اليوم جلسه مفتوحه على
المستوى الوزاري يتراسها وزير خارجيه
روسيا سيرجي لافروف الذي يتراس بلاده
المجلس للشهر الحالي وستشهد الجلسه مناقشه
تعدديه فعاله عبر الدفاع عن مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده كما يتراس لافروف جلسه
مناقشات حول الشرق الاوسط غدا وكان وزير
الخارجيه الروسي اشار الى ان الحقيقه التي
ستطرحها بلاده من منبر مجلس الامن ستكون
اكثر اهميه من المعلومات الغربيه المزعومه
ضد موسكو على حد قوله
انتقد وزير الخارجيه الروسي عدم اصدار
تاشيرات دخول الامريكيه للصحفيين الروس
الذين كانوا ضمن الوفد الروسي المتجه
لحضور اجتماعات مجلس الامن الدولي في
نيويورك واكد لافروف قبيل توجهه الى
نيويورك انا موسكو لن تنسى ولن تسامح
تقاعس الامريكيين عن منح تاشيره للصحفيين
الروس على حد وصفه
تغطيتنا للاحداث في السودان مستمره لكن
نتوقف لنعرض المقابله الخاصه مع عضو مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي لانسي جرام مع الزميله
معي تلقيت نلقاكم على راس الساعه في امان
الله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات